salut vous l'avez compris si vous avez
vu ma dernière vidéo je me pose plein de
questions sur ce que ça implique de
publier du contenu en ligne
quand on prétend diffuser de la
connaissance ce n'est pas anodin se
positionner comme source de savoir
voilà les questions que je voudrais
aborder aujourd'hui
d'abord comment font les autres
qu'est-ce qu'on peut identifier comme
type de chaîne youtube et où est ce que
je me situe là dedans
ensuite je voudrais me demander si le
fait de diffuser du savoir ou de
proposer des idées ne suppose pas
inévitablement de promouvoir nos désirs
nos sentiments n'est-il pas toujours
derrière une conviction une préférence
émotionnel quels sont les sentiments qui
se cache derrière nos idées ça me pousse
à me poser une question encore plus
difficile peut-être
quelle valeur l'attribution à la vérité
pourquoi la recherche dont ceux qui
revient aussi à se demander à quoi
prétendant nous quand nous prétendons
dire vrai enfin si la prétention à dire
vrai implique une valeur je vais me
demander s'il est possible de prendre la
parole sans imposer la valeur qu'on lui
associe c'est à dire d'une façon sans
prendre le pouvoir sans imposer son
point de vue assez ceux qui nous
écoutent
voilà j'espère que ça va être clair on
pourrait imaginer faire des familles je
ne prétends pas ici faire une taxinomie
exhaustive loin de là seulement un petit
éclairage pour commencer notre enquête
il y à celles et ceux qui ont une
expertise dans un domaine et qui en
présente le contenu de manière
globalement à contextuel par là je veux
dire que le contenu de la chaîne aurait
pu pour la plupart être identique il y a
dix vingt ou trente ans c'est en un sens
de la culture générale scientifique
donc il ya une expertise parce qu'on est
par exemple mathématicien historienne ou
géologues et humoriste ses chaînes
s'engagent différents niveaux de
difficulté ensuite il ya les chaînes qui
ont une expertise dans un domaine
pleinement impliqué dans l'organisation
de la société et qui pose donc
explicitement des questions éthiques et
politiques
ces chaînes sont ancrés dans leur temps
c'est leur fonction d'analysé une ou
plusieurs facettes du monde contemporain
sociologie économie philosophie
féminisme externe
enfin il y a les chaînes qui ne
revendique pas explicitement une
expertise scientifique mais promet un
contenu à
inventée à la méthode scientifique pour
la vie de tous les jours elles sont
plutôt tournés vers le monde actuel
puisqu'elle s'occupe de croyances qui
circulent concrètement dans la société
nucléaire paraît normal
homéopathie vaccins etc en même temps
elle privilégie un angle de lecture
individuelle au sens soit se concentre
sur ce que l'individu peut faire pour
progresser au sens large du terme
il ya sûrement d'autres familles mais je
crois que cette tripartition est déjà
actée rente la première famille dit
quelque chose comme cultivez-vous c'est
agréable
et en plus vous en sortirez enrichir
intellectuellement après tout pourquoi
pas la culture générale c'est pas trop
mon truc mais après tout pourquoi pas
j'avoue que je regarde quand même source
de comptoir de temps en temps parce que
le super marrantes
d'ailleurs comme elf et 1700 blague à la
minute je ne retiens rien d'autre donc
je peux pas dire vraiment que je me fais
une culture géologique la seconde
famille de chaîne youtube dit quelque
chose comme comprendre la société
demande de comprendre ces structures de
percevoir comme on l'a pouvoir
s'organise comment la domination ses
tableaux elle insiste pour rappeler que
la circulation des idées et des
croyances n'est pas le fait d'individus
libres mais qu'elle dépend étroitement
d'une organisation inégalitaire que la
société entretient sous couvert de
méritocratie équitable
cette phrase est un peu longue mais
l'idée est simple je voulais 10 secondes
pour la relève
la troisième famille dit quelque chose
comme développer votre esprit critique
c'est important pour vous protéger des
informations fallacieuses et pour éviter
de les diffuser à votre tour et moi
alors moi vous l'avez compris je suis
super convaincu par la deuxième famille
mais je n'ai pas cette expertise qui me
permettrait de parler en détail des
mécanismes de domination et de
l'organisation du pouvoir
l'information est philosophique disons
que je connais un tout petit peu trois
bonhommes spinoza wittgenstein et
deleuze
donc on pourrait être tenté de me mettre
dans la troisième famille car c'est vrai
en un sens que je m'adresse à l'individu
qui veut devenir plus fort en quelque
sorte mais en fait pas vraiment ce
qu'ils m'ont éloigné je crois c'est que
je suis beaucoup moins animée qu'elle
par la quête de vérité au sens usuel
parler des halles d'un progrès
intellectuel est beaucoup plus par la
quête d'apaisement chez moi devenir plus
fort est avant tout synonyme de plus
gentil plus d'empathie
plus altruiste je ne me sens pas trop à
l'aise avec ce qui pourrait s'apparenter
à une responsabilisation de l'individu
je cherche moins à débloquer des
croyances fallacieuse car des noix et
des problèmes mentaux et je vise moins
le scepticisme une forme de sérénité
vis-à-vis de notre vie mentale
c'est cet idéal un peu paradoxal de
développement personnel non compétitif
qu'on évoquait ici le but au départ
c'est d'apaiser une relation aux autres
et notre relation à nous mêmes je pars
du principe qu'il est impossible d'être
concerné par son entourage
si on est constamment en conflit avec sa
propre vie par extension qu'il est plus
difficile de se préoccuper des autres et
du monde dans lequel on vit
si on est régulièrement assailli le
stimuli désagréable si je me sens
agressée par certains de mes sentiments
si dépenses m angoisse
si je suis impatient ça peut même
provoquer l'effet inverse je développe
une peur de l'existence et une crainte
générale vis-à-vis du monde extérieur ce
qui me rend plus facilement agressif
face à quelqu'un qui pense différemment
de moi ce qui limite également ma
capacité à imaginer le point de vue
d'autrui car bien sûr si on est capable
d'envisager la souffrance d'autrui on
s'expose à une forme de violence
c'est dur de ressentir la douleur des
autres ça suppose être un peu fort
ceux qui travaillent pour plus de
justice se confrontent régulièrement à
une réalité difficile à encaisser ça use
en un sens ce qu'on gagne en acuité
social on risque de le perdre en
notre personnel et donc moi je me dis il
faut aider ceux qui souffrent et il faut
aider ceux qui aident ceux qui souffrent
à savoir peut-être les soulager de
certaines tensions mental qui rendent la
vie difficile au fond au point de départ
il est un peu bancal puisque j'essaie de
conseillers d'opposition pas forcément
toujours compatibles à savoir associer
les impératifs politiques de la lutte
pour plus de justice sociale d'un côté
et le désir de promouvoir une vie
mentale apaisé et plein d'amour pour
autrui de l'autre oui en gros pour
résumer je suis un peu le cul entre deux
chaises comme ça entre les punks et les
hippies et peut-être que c'est voué à
l'échec
mais j'ai envie d'essayer quand même en
un autre sens pour être parfaitement
honnête elle me paraît pas si bancal
cette position parce que je suis super
convaincu d'un truc chaque idée implique
un ou plusieurs affecte chaque affecte
implique une ou plusieurs idées et j'ai
vraiment l'impression que si on
expérimente autant de malentendus et de
quiproquos dans la vie c'est précisément
parce qu'on prend à envoyer un signal
composé d'idées et que l'autre reçoit un
signal composé d'affect quand je vois
des malentendus entre deux personnes qui
se parlent devant moi ou quand moi même
je n'arrive pas à me faire comprendre ou
à comprendre l'autre c'est rarement
vraiment vraiment parce que le contenu
conceptuel et super subtil et technique
ça arrive bien sûr je ne veux pas nier
mais très souvent pour ne pas dire la
plupart du temps j'ai l'impression que
le malentendu né d implication affective
liés aux mots employés jeudi x et pour
moi derrière x il y a une idée une
représentation abstraite quelque chose
qui m'apparaît purement intelligible je
ne me rends pas forcément compte au
moment où j'exprime x que cette
représentation abstraite elle est en
fait associé dans mon esprit à certains
sentiments et je ne me rends pas compte
qu'en plus x va être associé à d'autres
sentiments que les miens chez mon
interlocutrice exemple que j'aime
particulièrement
je dis à quelqu'un il n'y a pas de libre
arbitre
personne n'est libre de décider de quoi
que ce soit bon pour moi cette idée elle
est clairement convaincante sur le seul
plan de la démonstration abstraite entre
l'inconscient le fonctionnement du
cerveau les incitations produite par la
société héritage culturel
je ne vois pas comment on peut continuer
à défendre l'idée que notre décision
pourrait être libre je sais bien qu'on a
l'impression d'avoir une marge de
manoeuvre mais il me paraît évident que
cette impression est illusoire et que
derrière il n'y a rien de bien solide
pour soutenir cette impression mais en
vrai quand je dis ça je dis aussi
quelque chose qui me tient à coeur
quelque chose qui représente pour moi un
horizon affectif favorable en gros pour
moi c'est synonyme de joie
j'ai envie que les gens prennent
conscience que libre arbitre est une
illusion parce que je crois que c'est
très libérateur
parce que je crois donc à tort ou à
raison que ça nous ferait du bien à tous
de lâcher cette croyance parce que je
crois que ça apaise la relation que l'on
tisse avec nos propres décisions et
aussi parce que je crois que ça
transforme complètement le rapport qu'on
a avec autrui
évidemment on se sent beaucoup moins
agressé par le comportement de quelqu'un
si on perçoit cette personne comme une
marionnette aux prises avec des forces
qui la dépasse et donc on a beaucoup
plus de compassion pour elle on la
regarde comme notre égal parce qu'on
sait qu'on est aussi nous mêmes une
marionnette donc je me dis après ivoire
vitres etc soyons solidaires dans la
reconnaissance des causes qui nous
déterminent faut pas se leurrer si je
parle du libre arbitre
c'est avant tout parce que pour moi
l'abandonner est synonyme de juin mais
peut-être que pour mon interlocutrice
l'idée que le libre arbitre est une
illusion c'est au contraire source
d'angoissé elle pressent que l'abandon
de cette croyance est synonyme de ko et
aussi de perdre identité que sa vie
deviendra absurde
on pourrait simplifier comme ça les
implication affective sens libre arbitre
il n'y a ni réussite ni échec personnel
donc ça fait disparaître les émotions
liées à la réussite et à l'échec
peut-être que mon interlocutrice
angoisse à l'idée d'abandonner la joie
qui accompagne le sentiment d'avoir
réussi quelque chose et de mon côté
peut-être que je jubile à l'idée
d'abandonner l'angoissent qui accompagne
l'impression d'avoir échoué
je pensais parler de la conscience
humaine et en fait j'ai exprimé mes
désirs alors que faire comment trancher
j'ai l'impression que plein de gens le
réflexe de dire
en tranches en fonction de la vérité ce
qui est vrai devant leur porte et donc
si c'est vrai que le libre arbitre est
une illusion
il est légitime de vouloir déconstruire
les périodes de l'autre la version
caricaturale de cette position c'est
vidéo qui dit taxe bancaire battu frings
c'est un gros idiot oui là je m'autorise
à le dire c'est un gros idiot je vais
pas rentrer dans le détail simplement
porter la contradiction qui me saute aux
yeux
vouloir s'en remettre au factuel c'est
vouloir s'en remettre au factuel
c'est suivre sa volonté et donc ses
désirs ses sentiments il faut rappeler
que si on va se préoccuper des
sentiments des uns et des autres parce
qu'en fait on organise sa société que
pour ça on fait des progrès
technologiques pour améliorer le confort
on établit des lois pour ne pas avoir
peur à chaque coin de rue ont fait
avancer la médecine pour limiter la
souffrance on se divertit pour oublier
nos soucis pour les plaisirs tout ce
qu'on fait est motivée par une recherche
de sentiments j'ai l'impression que
c'est donc normal de les prendre en
compte dans notre rapport aux croyances
d'autrui
mais ça suppose aussi d'interroger les
applications derrière des croyances on
ne veut pas se contenter de dire x 3 x
il faut se demander quels sont les
croyances attaché avec croyance aux
knicks
et aussi comment la croyance en x peut
cohabiter harmonieusement ou non avec
une croyance en onyx plutôt que
d'expliquer à mon interlocutrice que
j'ai raison de ne pas croire au libre
arbitre
peut-être je ferais jamais de lui
expliquer d'où l'intérêt que je trouve
dans le fait de ne pas croire au libre
arbitre
c'est à dire en fait révélé les valeurs
attachées à ma croyance ceux qui peuvent
aussi me permettre d'ailleurs de lui
montrer ce qui m'embête dans le fait de
croire au libre arbitre
je pourrais lui dire par exemple que la
croyance dans le libre arbitre favorise
la croyance dans la méritocratie et
qu'on a désormais plus trop de doutes
sur les limites de ce modèle
les systèmes qui repose sur l'idée que
l'individu est responsable son succès
produisent beaucoup d'inégalités donc
d'une certaine façon ce que je pourrais
trouver chouette dans le projet d'une
chaîne youtube
ce serait pas tellement de débloquer les
croyances pour se rapprocher d'un idéal
de rationalité épidémique mais plutôt de
mettre au jour les implications éthiques
et donc affective et existentielles des
croyances c'est ce que j'essaie de faire
je demandais tout à l'heure comment
trancher dans un débat entre deux
personnes mais en fait la question c'est
peut-être plus tôt faute il tranché
j'ai parfois l'impression qu'il ya un
implicite très fort qui consiste à
penser que lors d'une opposition il a
forcément une des deux personnes qui a
plus raison que l'autre et il faut
identifier qui comme je lui ai déjà dit
dans d'autres vidéos je trouverais plus
pertinent de se demander quels sont les
désirs
quelles sont les valeurs qui motivent
notre croyance on pourrait parler un peu
moins de ce qu'on pense être vrai et un
peu plus de ce qu'on valorise je sais
qu'on aime comprendre
je sais qu'on est rassurée à l'idée
qu'on a une représentation adéquate de
la réalité je sais qu'on adore le
sentiment de maîtriser une idée
comprendre ça donne un sentiment de
puissance et donc du coup on cherche à
savoir et beaucoup de contenus
disponibles sur internet
beaucoup de travaux de vulgarisation
consiste justement à proposer ce
sentiment de puissance liée au fait
d'apprendre
on propose des synthèses on dit regardez
cette vidéo et j'ai ce serait les vous
serez ce qu'il en est du sujet knicks
alors on regarde on lit on se sent un
peu plus intelligent on trouve ça
agréable
c'est le sujet de la vidéo sur hegel et
lao tseu mais dire que la recherche de
la vérité renvoie à la recherche d'un
centime en puissance c'est important
parce que ça souligne que le savoir est
un instrument de domination connaître
les lois de la physique pour dominer la
nature savoir être lucide pour dominer
ses émotions connaître les bons
arguments pour dominer une discussion
connaître les points faibles de son
adversaire pour dominer une situation
conflictuelle savoir la vérité confère
une autorité
celui qui sait le vrai peut trancher
juge est évaluée ordonné donc plus la
vérité à laquelle on prétend est vaste
plus il ya de puissance en jeu pour le
dire autrement plus grand est le nombre
de gens sensés reconnaître la vérité
plus grande à la puissance qu'elle
confère ce qui est vrai pour 2 personnes
n'implique pas une forte autorité
ce qui est vrai pour 1000 personnes
implique une puissance déjà bien plus
importante
on peut tromper mille fois une personne
mais son patron une vérité universelle
serait donc synonyme d'une puissance
gigantesque je fais un pari
psychologique celui qui cherche une
vérité unique et absolue est avide de
puissance et celui qui refuse l'idée que
la vérité puisse être fragmenté locales
relatives à un point de vue je crois
qu'il est possible que ce soit à cause
de l' angoisse que suscite en lui la
perspective d'une perte de puissance
et même s'il ne pense pas la détenir
d'ailleurs cette vérité
il peut être rassurant de penser qu'il
existe une vérité universelle même si
elle nous reste inconnue pour toujours
une vérité universelle absolue quelque
part cela veut dire qu'il ya une
puissance d'ordonnancement et les
synonymes d'ordre elle fait rempart au
chaos
on aime penser qu'il ya un savoir qui
pourrait trancher toutes les discussions
un dernier mot en quelque sorte
donc il semble bien qu'on a fait de la
vérité une valeur je crois que personne
ne cherche le vrai par pur amour du vrai
on cherche le vrai parce qu on part du
principe qu'il vaut mieux ne pas se
tromper il vaut mieux ne pas croire des
choses fausses
en tant qu'elle est une valeur la vérité
n'est ni libre ni indépendante
c'est ça que ça veut dire quand on dit
que la vérité dépend d'un point de vue
ce n'est pas forcément un point de vue
subjectif
ça peut être un point de vue un
personnel par exemple si on pense du
point de vu de tel ou tel objectif
du point de vue d'une fonction une
théorie peut être jugé du point de vue
de sa capacité à prédire des phénomènes
donc du point de vue de la prédiction un
techno stick sera jugé du point de vue
de la maladie de la santé c'est à dire
du point de vue de la résolution du
problème qu'est la pathologie quitte à
ce que ça implique de conclure qu'il
n'ya pas de traitement possible si c'est
le cas d'ailleurs une interprétation
psychologique peut être jugé du point de
vue de sa correspondance avec un état
mental
si je dis cassandre a de la sympathie
pour bérénice cela peut être vrai ou
faux selon ce qui se passe consciemment
ou inconsciemment dans l'esprit de
cassandre donc la vérité est une valeur
en tant qu elle implique un point de vue
une situation on se contrefout de la
vérité quand elle ne concerne pas la
situation à laquelle on est confronté
imaginez qu'on demande à un médecin
qu'un traitement choisir et qu'il
réponde en formulant la théorie de la
relativité d'einstein se serait échoué
c'est pas faux mais ses cheveux
de manière générale quand on sort de la
bulle des sciences formelle ou
expérimentales et donc dès qu'on prétend
parler de la société la vérité est
étroitement liée à un contexte comme
s'est magnifiquement résumé dans cette
vidéo que je vous invite chaudement à
regarder tellement les chouettes
bref un point de vue c'est une manière
de voir une manière d'organiser la
réalité ce n'est jamais indépendant des
objectifs conscient et inconscient qu'on
se donne donc c'est lié à une manière de
désir et de produire d'autres valeurs
c'est une façon de donner du sens à la
réalité tenait du sens parce que ça lui
donne une forme de cohérence et que ça
permet d'interagir avec elle donc d'agir
tout court donc d'agir pour quelque
chose en vue d'atteindre un objectif
il s'agit bien de développer une
puissance puissance de prédire puissance
de soigner ^ comprends je parle
puissance mais au fond on pourrait aussi
parler de pouvoir revendiquer le vrai
c'est affirmer le pouvoir d'imposer le
point de vue l'organisation du réel qui
nous est favorable
parler au nom de la vérité c'est asseoir
son pouvoir sur ce qu'ils écoutent et en
ce sens c'est une violence
même quand ça part d'une bonne intention
comme en médecine par exemple ce que dit
deleuze dans l'abécédaire son propos
me semblait clairement il y a une
expérience qui touche à l'humiliation
dans la relation aux médecins à cause de
ce regard surplombant de son savoir il a
en théorie la puissante de changer
beaucoup de choses dans notre vie c'est
à pouvoir terrible d'autant qu'il est
dit que la bonne santé comme le prêtre
chez nietzsche définit ce qu'est la
bonne vie il incarne une norme le
pouvoir lié à une norme
vous imaginez en psychiatrie le pouvoir
de déclarer quelqu'un psychotique par
exemple c'est quelque chose quand même
ce n'est pas rien de dire à une personne
votre réalité de production pathologique
bon je simplifie mais vous voyez l'idée
c'est l'ultime violence non les versions
+12 consiste à dire seulement votre
vérité n'est pas la meilleure possible
mais ça reste brutale même si c'est
implicite et l'espace justement ce
qu'impliquent les vidéos qui prétendre
enseigner une autre manière de penser ne
dit elle pas quelque chose comme votre
mental gagnerait à se nourrir de ce
n'est pas anodin
encore une fois que ça part d'une bonne
intention ou non si on al'air
convaincant on se met en position
d'influencer l'esprit des gens tout
simplement
donc pour résumer ce troisième moment on
pourrait dire que prétend de pouvoir
dire vrai c'est prétendre à des formes
de pouvoir pouvoir décréter ce qui est
réel et ce qui ne l'est pas ce qui est
juste et ce qui est injuste ce qui est
bon et ce qui est mauvais c'est aussi le
pouvoir diriger une norme le tracé mines
définitive qui distingue ce qui entre et
ce qui sort de la norme et c'est pas
anodin du tout parce que l'on a tous
tendance à se juger soi même et à juger
les autres en fonction de la norme en
fonction de notre position par rapport à
une norme de manière générale celui qui
se propose d'aider de conseillers de
guérir d'enseigner il se met dans une
position de surplomb qui assoit un
pouvoir
donc moi je suis un peu coincé j'ai
envie de parler
j'ai envie d'expliquer les trucs j'ai
envie d'aider mais j'ai pas envie de me
retrouver dans une position de
domination
alors que ça a l'air quand même
inévitable quand on se positionne en
sachant c'est relou j'avais écrit dans
le programme de la chaîne
bête et méchant pour être un peu moins
bête est plus sympa insistant sur un peu
plus sympa parce que je ne veux pas
faire croire que je vais diffuser des
purs idée je veux même répété que ce
n'est pas possible que chaque prise de
parole et chargé affectivement mais du
coup la question je me pose c'est
comment faire en sorte de diffuser des
affects apaisant c'est à dire en fait
comment parler sans que la parole soit
un instrument de pouvoir
comment parler sans imposer à celles et
ceux qui écoutent de voir les choses
comme je les vois est seulement possible
je ne suis pas sûr on est tellement
habitué à coder nos affects en idées
qu'on ne sait même plus exactement voir
quels sentiments est impliquée par cette
croyance j'aimerais bien ici réussir à y
voir clair là dedans et donc parvenir à
partager des affects de manière
transparente
mais je ne suis pas sûr de la
faisabilité du truc est ce que vous
voyez l'écart qu'il ya entre les paroles
attribuées au christ et ce qu'est
devenue l'église
visiblement même quand on balance des
choses aussi peu sujette aux quiproquos
que ton prochain comme toi même
il y a des réinterprétations chelou en
fait les gens vont réagir à cette phrase
à la mesure de ce qu'ils peuvent
affectivement et donc l'appliquer à la
mesure de leurs capacités
voilà un autre exemple que j'aime
beaucoup parce qu'il est vraiment simple
et que personne ne l'appliquent jésus
dit si tu veux être fait pas beaucoup de
chrétiens appliquée à la lettre
certains donnent régulièrement une
partie de ce qu'ils gagnent d'autres
donne de temps en temps alors même
qu'ils possèdent beaucoup
que se passe-t-il pour qu'une phrase si
simple soit évacuée si facilement
pourquoi ce autorise-t-on à croire qu'il
est possible d'être chrétien sans donner
la plupart de ses biens matériels
la limite n'est pas intellectuel le sens
est simple la limite est affective
on est capable de comprendre la phrase
de l'évangile mais on n'est pas capable
de donner je dis ça pour insister sur la
dimension affective de la compréhension
comprendre l'idée de l'impératif moral
du don n'a rien à voir avec une
compréhension qui permet de ressentir
cet impératif prendre la parole c'est
s'adresser aux capacités intellectuelles
mais aussi aux capacités affective de
ceux qui nous écoutent
je ne prends pas l'exemple du christ
parce que j'ai autant de respect pour le
personnage historique que j'ai de
perplexité pour l'église en tant
qu'institution je prends cet exemple
parce que je crois que toute personne
qui ose prendre la parole publique
pour tenter de faire du bien avec ces
mots jouent au prophète en quelque sorte
à des degrés divers bien entendu jeudi
jouer au prophète sans condescendance
je ne crois pas que les chaînes
mentionné plus haut se prennent pour des
prophètes mais j'ai bien l'impression
qu'elle pense prêcher la bonne parole et
je serai bien malhonnête de l'enfer
leurs proches puisque c'est très
clairement ce que je fais aussi quand je
parle ici au fond derrière il y a une
voix qui dit voyez mes amis et voir les
choses ainsi et je crois que cela vous
fera du bien à vous et à vos proches et
accroît le nombre de chaînes youtube de
livres de développement personnel ou de
podcasts
il ya encore un vrai besoin de prophète
un vrai besoin de paroles sages qui aide
à vivre
donc je me demande comment je procéder
si on veut sans préciser le raisonnement
jusque là voilà ce qu'on peut dire
objectif je veux et des prémices 1
je ne peux aider qu'est la mesure de mon
expérience de ma compréhension du monde
prémices 2 mon expérience et ma
compréhension du monde sont déterminés
par mon quotidien
donc également par mon statut social par
les privilèges et les limites qui le
définissent facilité al embauche
héritage culturel capital symbolique et
c'est ma vision du monde et colorée par
mon statut prémices 3 ce statut est
grosso modo celui d'un dominant premise
4 or aider c'est plutôt aider ceux qui
sont dominés ceux qui subissent des
traitements injustes des inégalités
systématique premie 5
comme je ne vis pas la même vie que je
ne sais pas ce qu'ils ressentent je ne
peux pas savoir ce dont ils ont besoin
conclusion il faut trouver un moyen de
déborder ma seule expérience et
conception du monde
nouvelle question comment
rappelons au passage que ceux qui rêvent
des faits ou du falsifiable ne suffit
pas pour aborder rigoureusement les
questions sociales liées à l'expérience
concrète que les gens font de leur
existence
je répète ce qui relève des faits ou du
fassi fiable ne suffit pas pour aborder
rigoureusement les questions sociales
liées à l'expérience concrète que les
gens font de leur existence
donc hors méthode scientifique
comment faire la première idée qui me
vient c'est en un sens d'ouvrir ma
parole et je crois qu'il ya deux
manières d'ouvrir sa parole 1
la collaboration faire intervenir d'une
façon ou d'une autre des gens qui ont
accès à des expériences qui me sont
inconnus
et deux la question posée des questions
ouvertes les adresser spontanément à
celles et ceux qui regardent pour faire
bouger le regard sans trop appuyer une
orientation plutôt qu'une autre
passer d'un mode explicatif je vous
explique ce que j'ai compris à un mode
interrogatif
je partage avec vous certaines des
questions qui me travaille cela
n'empêche pas par ailleurs de partager
certaines de mes réflexions mais
diversifier le contenu est privilégié
les angles d'approché interrogative me
semble une bonne manière de déminer le
terrain une bonne chaîne youtube compte
tenu de l'objectif que je me donne ce
serait une chaîne qui évolue et qui se
transforme en fonction de ce qu'elle
apprend d'elle même
parce qu'il y a une responsabilité dans
le fait de publier du contenu il y à un
apprentissage on se confronte à fait à
deux questions vertigineuses
que dire et quand on croit avoir réussi
à répondre comment le dire et c'est ça
qui me conduit à avoir cette réflexion
j'anticipe un retour possible et à mon
avis qui pêche par naïveté le contenu
est en ligne
les gens sont libres de le regarder ou
non et de se faire leur propre opinion
on est fort personne sauf que c'est une
grossière simplification ayant eu le
privilège de faire des études
supérieures assez poussée disons j'ai
appris à maîtriser des outils rhétorique
à manier la langue avec une certaine
aisance de sorte que j'ai appris à
présenter des idées de façon didactique
pour qu'elles soient convaincantes
donc même si ce n'est pas mon intention
gillis de la rhétorique comme tout le
monde d'ailleurs pour proposer mon
discours sur le meilleur joueur possible
et on est tous très vulnérable face à ce
type de présentation
combien de fois ai-je été convaincu par
le discours qui se pose est simplement
parce que la présentation des idées
étaient pertinentes et bien si je
n'avais eu accès qu'à un seul décès du
discours je serais reparti avec une
conviction unique donc j'insiste il est
indispensable à mon sens qu'une chaîne
youtube déconstruisent explicitement son
propre contenu pour éviter ce type
d'accueil
j'ai une obligation morale à vous dire
ce que je cherche à faire et comment
j'essaie de le faire sinon il ya danger
mais il ya une deuxième idée à explorer
reprenons le raisonnement et
arrêtons-nous sur la 4e prémices en fait
on peut se demander si le meilleur moyen
compte tenu de mes compétences pour
aider les dominer n'ai pas d'attenté une
indirecte à savoir de s'adresser aux
autres hommes blancs six jeunes
hétérosexuels
pour tenter de les convaincre de la
légitimité du combat féministe
intersectionnelle etc
en fait cela me rappelle l'opposition
entre la proche de 10 mots thierry d'un
côté et un brio demandé à la rhubarbe de
l'autre à propos de la meilleure manière
d'utiliser le lsd en gros ils sont tous
les trois d'accord pour dire que la
substance un potentiel existentielle et
politique inouï ils ont l'intimé
conviction que le lsd prix d'un certain
conditions peu pour aller vite rendre
l'être humain meilleur que c'est un
super moyen de faire progresser
l'humanité
mais du coup quelle stratégie adopter
viry a décidé de diffuser le lsd un
maximum pour libérer les masses tout en
communiquant activement sur
l'utilisation qui est jugé adéquat du
produit heureusement les hubbard eux
étaient convaincus que c'était la
meilleure manière de faire peur aux
autorités et de rang la substance
illégale dont de ce point de vue il faut
reconnaître qu'il n'avait pas tout à
fait tort eux avaient une autre
stratégie en tête afin d'exploiter le
potentiel révolutionnaire du lsd
il s'agissait au contraire d'en faire
consommer aux membres de l'élite afin
qu'ils changent radicalement leur
manière de diriger le monde
j'ai un peu choisi cet exemple pour
teese est une série que je prépare
tranquillement et qui compte beaucoup
pour moi
mais en fait l'analogie fonctionne et
cela ouvre sur une autre question
massive
faut-il parler pour aider les dominer ou
pour changer ce qui domine ce qui me
permet de terminer en renvoyant à un
philosophe de l'éducation que j'aime
beaucoup
sébastien charbonnier dans un ouvrage
collectif consacré à la question de
l'éducation de la liberté il a écrit un
texte intitulé l'aliénation de l'autre
un diagnostic impossible en spin o dia
il y défend l'idée selon laquelle
l'émancipation ne peut pas se produire
de manière unilatérale
il n'ya pas d'autre voie éducative que
celle ci nous nous aimons si prompts
ensemble ceci revient à démontrer par
l'absurde que tout unilatéralité dans ce
domaine ce le couvrir de la
bienveillance ou d'une mystérieuse
générosité conduit aux effets exactement
inverses de ceux qu'elle prétend
permettre c'est à dire qu on m en 6 pas
autrui il n'y a pas d'un côté d'aliéner
et de l'autre l'émancipation
le prisonnier est le sauveur
l'enseignant ou plus généralement celui
qui prend la parole en tant que source
de connaissances ne doit pas adopter
cette posture qui consiste à penser
qu'il vient offrir le savoir libérateur
au contraire il faut penser je ne peux
vous aider à vous émanciper que dans la
mesure où vous m'aider à bien principe
et en retour je ne peux être
émancipateur que si je cherche également
être émancipée je ne peux émancipé
autrui que si je compte sur lui pour
l'émanciper c'est à dire que ce n'est
possible qu'en donnant une légitimité
forte au point de vue d'autrui sur le
monde
donc en considérant sa perspective avec
intérêt et si jeudi avec intérêt c'est
que ça suppose même pas de faire appel à
un pur altruisme désintéressée parce que
c'est écoute attentive et respectueuse
va faire bouger notre perspective
et c'est précisément là que réside le
processus émancipateur dans le fait de
s'ouvrir à une autre manière de
percevoir la réalité dans le fait de
changer au contact d'autrui prendre la
parole pour exprimer son point de vue
sur le monde
en espérant que ça aide ceux qui
écoutent c'est prendre de risques
d'abord celui d'aline et autrui en lui
imposant une perspective sur le réel
jeudi imposé mais c'est pas forcément de
force peut-être que c'est parce qu'on
est très convaincant dans notre manière
d'exposer des idées peut-être que c'est
parce qu'on jouit d'une aura et d'un a
priori très favorable parce qu'on
représente une institution
donc on incarne une forme d' argument
d'autorité le fait est qu'on peut faire
passer le message à autrui qu'il ferait
mieux de voir les choses comme nous
ensuite c'est celui de céline est
soi-même en s'enfermant dans son propre
point de vue on le régime dit fiant
parce qu on se convainc que c'est la
meilleure façon de voir le monde si ce
n'est pas l'unique façon de voir le
monde parce qu'on est tous sujets aux
biais de confirmation nourrir l'esprit
critique pour reprendre l'expression de
foucauld ces lettres pas tellement
gouverné par notre propre point de vue
du moment est la meilleure manière de ne
pas se faire prisonnier de son propre
point de vue
c'est de s'ouvrir à des perspectives
différentes ma chaîne youtube idéal
c'est donc celle qui vise l'émancipation
mutuelle et mettre ça en place
pas évident à bientôt pour voir si on y
arrive